hola santiago lo conocen como el abogado
es el líder de la caravana luís rey
garcía villagrán quien el pasado lunes
salió con 15.000 migrantes desde
tapachula recorriendo el sur del estado
de chiapas y hoy aquí en macas tp hizo
varios anuncios importantes uno de ellos
es que las oficinas y aduanas regionales
de weeks lay de marcaste pec han
entregado a la fecha ocho mil formatos
de múltiples de migración es decir el
documento que les permite a los
migrantes por 30 días transitar
libremente por todo el territorio
mexicano sin embargo hacen falta otros
7.000 de ellos lo que recomienda el
abogado a los migrantes es que desde
aquí tomen buses en 20 personas de
grupos de 20 personas llegue en la
ciudad de mexico y una vez allí asistan
a una nueva oficina de migración para
pedir ahora la visa humanitaria un
documento que se les puede entregar en
una semana y con el 'juan pueden estar
un año en territorio mexicano y otro de
los anuncios muy importantes que hizo es
que va a denunciar ante la fiscalía
general de la nación la fiscalidad de
mexico a la directora del centro de
reclusión de emigrantes por todas las
denuncias que se han recopilado de
tortura física y tortura mental andrés
un tema clave cuál es la situación
humanitaria que están viviendo los
migrantes y qué otras opciones les
quedarían si no obtienen los permisos de
migración
bueno las condiciones no son las mejores
los migrantes están bajo
bajo el tema climático el bajo efectos
climáticos bastante fuertes en el día un
sol pleno en las noches fuertes
temporales lluvia se les dan inundados
sus carpas se les da mojado toda su ropa
muy importante que tampoco tienen comida
los líderes han traído aquí hoy tres mil
piezas de pan 40 apoyos para que se
repartan de una presa de pollo por
cabeza pero es muy insuficiente y se
está privilegiando a los niños y a las
mujeres y el anuncio posterior es que si
no se les entrega este documento
migratorio por el cual están esperando y
acampando aquí varios días en diferentes
puntos del estado sur de chiapas pues
seguirá seguirá la caravana y saldrán de
chiapas a oaxaca y seguirán caminando